let's jump into this first story we got
this from the post millennial John
fetterman co-sponsor Senate Bill despite
being institutionalized since February
15th Letterman's office has not said who
is co-sponsoring legislation with his
name on it while he remains
institutionalized a senior aide revealed
that fetterman would be hospitalized for
up to two months so it's clearly not him
I guess that's the important point is
they're saying he's co-sponsoring this
bill but it's probably just a member of
his staff and uh I got to show you this
right here from Twitter
or from John cardillo on Twitter he says
this is from February 25th it was a
while ago being told that fetterman is
essentially brain brain dead
and and uh let me let's start over being
told that fetamine is essentially brain
dead and it's being hidden because
keeping it in him in office until August
18th avoids a special election which
Republicans would most certainly win
this must be investigated so here's the
best part about this tweet there's the
the the context gets added to it and it
says readers edit context they thought
people might want to know the August
18th date is no significance if a
senator from Pennsylvania passes away a
replacement appointed by the governor
will serve until the next special
election oh thank you for the fact check
Twitter no uh no fact check on whether
or not Veteran's brain dead or not that
one they didn't so that's I saw that and
I was like okay
the a bunch of users said no no no there
won't be a special election he's
probably brain dead but they'll just you
know replace it the 18th doesn't matter
they'll just replace him or something so
is is fetterman brain they're not
debating the brain dead part right
that's what I thought was funny I'm like
you'd think they'd be like there's no
evidence to suggest that John fetterman
is effectively brain dead he was
institutionalized with depression that's
not really a medical term is it brain
dead I mean uh it might might be I don't
know and are they is this like a
cover-up of a suicide attempt no no
struggling with depression the
depression is probably fake I feel like
that's the fake part yeah he's probably
in the hospital because his brain
doesn't work
um brain death is a thing uh it's
permanent irreversible and complete loss
of brain function except for the brain
stem right ah
I don't know the the part that controls
breathing or whatever but they do say
it's irreversible so you know let me let
me hyperbolic in this situation we'll
we'll do an informal poll of the of the
audience we'll ask the audience what is
more likely knowing fetterman's health
and medical history that he is depressed
after winning you know his dream
election and checked himself into a
hospital where he'll be for up to two
months or the man who suffered a stroke
not that long ago and still can't
understand words had some kind of
recurring health issue that has injured
his brain further I think that
depression put a one in the chat if you
think he's just depressed and two if you
think he's brain dead I I think the
Democrat Party is the worst senior care
home I've ever seen I mean between
fetterman and Biden they cannot find out
I mean they never know where these guys
are how do we not know where John
fetterman is I don't know how do we not
know if he's brain dead
well you know I'm always I always I
always roll my eyes a little bit at
stuff like this it is convenient for
conservatives in the right to be able to
say he's brain dead because the dude's
basically not around so in the world of
politics this is
I don't know par for the course guy goes
to the hospital immediately come out
with some salacious rumor that's going
to shock and damage the perception of
this party but I'm kind of like of all
the rumors they could have the dude who
had a stroke not that long ago who can't
understand words suffering another
stroke is completely plausible because
we talked about this before people who
suffer Strokes are at risk for suffering
them again and then all of a sudden
dudes in the hospital for several weeks
and get this his wife is gone Giselle
fetterman children take trip to Canada
in Wake of senators hospitalization
rightful looking woman that's what gets
me even if he's not brain dead right
what in what world when anyone you care
about is hospitalized because they're so
depressed do you flee the country
I think people were ragging on her
and a lot of uh like on Twitter they're
like stop making fun of fetterman's wife
you're you're bad people and it's like
dude her husband's depressed and in the
hospital for weeks and she just went on
vacation with her kids that is like that
that's worse than what Ted Cruz did like
with Ted Cruz he went on vacation during
that ice storm and it's like well he was
with his family though you know at the
very least he cares about his family
this is like the sender's wife whose
husband is a senator not only fleeing
the state but also fleeing her husband
who is you know convalesced that's dark
if he's just depressed then what is the
reason to hospitalize unless they think
that he's a danger to himself
like I don't know I guess he checked
himself if you're depressed that's the
last like a Hospital's the last place
you should
and
they would just ship you off to a
long-term medical facility that's not
Hospital this guy's a cucumber he's a
cucumber it just doesn't add up to me
and they assign him this authoritarian
looking school teacher woman everybody
thought Ruth Bader Ginsburg died that
one time they're like where is she she's
dead and then she pops up a few months
later like I'm still here and you know
and so I wouldn't be surprised if
fetterman you know pops up later because
you can't if someone really was brain
dead then they can't keep that covered
up forever so I I wonder if he's I think
injury makes more sense recurring injury
makes more sense but I don't know about
brain dead I think the depression makes
a lot of sense whenever someone uh
suffers a head trauma especially
Fighters it's pretty common in the fight
they be they have all sorts of chemical
imbalance a lot of bad things can happen
emotionally to people with head trauma
so if he had a stroke it's very likely
that confusion brings on depression
maybe that lead could have led the
stress additionally could have led to
another episode or another injury as
well but I I wouldn't I think the
depression for sure what's what's that
thing he's got where he can't understand
words anymore
that was that was the big thing like he
can hear when you talk but all he hears
is like
and so he that's problematic it's very
yeah so during during the debates there
was a monitor and when they would talk
it would translate the text to speech so
they could look at it and then read it
and it was causing him problems yeah he
had the cheat screen I wonder if just it
got to the point where he's in office he
just can't do the job and none of us
thought he could do the job
and so you know he's like so humiliating
maybe look if he is in the hospital
I would I would say this if it's not a
recurring injury then it's political and
they probably said we can't work with
you because your brain's broken go to
the hospital and take a few weeks to see
if you can get your head straight and
we'll have your AIDS take care of the
job for you and we'll send your wife too
Canada Canada in the winter is a great
does she have family there maybe she got
family there uh here's the story from
Penn Live what happens when your husband
or father a senator to boot checks into
the hospital and media truck Circle your
home pack the kids up and head to Canada
Giselle fetterman says fetterman
recently explained on Twitter that she
and her kid and their and her kids left
Pennsylvania for a family trip to
Niagara Falls to get away from the media
coverage surrounding her husband's
recovery at Walter Reed Medical Center
in Washington DC fetterman checked
himself in to receive treatment for
clinical depression on February 16th
according to his chief of staff Adam
gentelson he is there on a voluntary
basis while his family navigates how to
deal with the grief that comes with such
a hospitalization
Giselle fetterman said she and her son
ziplined across Niagara Falls and the
family did other scary things together
this is just a really really weird story
isn't it it sounds sick it sounds sick
what
believing him
I see they go into the hospital room and
he's like incapacitated almost like uh
and but he's like I want you to be happy
kind of thing like do it I would go
she's like okay we'll do it we'll go
ziplining over Niagara Falls
like voice generator you can talk no he
just can't understand the words that are
said to him I don't know he could be in
a coma for all I know I don't know
that's the reason I don't know remember
when Trump got coveted and everyone was
like oh he's dying he's dying they're
covering it up
um all the establishment journalists who
didn't want to seem like they were
establishment were like I hope he dies
they're really ugly people I want the
best for John fetterman I want him to be
healthy which is why I wanted him to
lose because no person that just got a
had a stroke should be taking on that
kind of mental stress and obviously and
this is why because it's the same thing
with Joe Biden I genuinely feel bad for
both Joe Biden and fetterman I feel like
it's elder abuse what they're doing man
Joe is putting them through the ringer
Feinstein's in the hospital right now
but that's shingle yeah but but still
like how old is she how can someone look
up her age so okay so we'd even bring
this up we should have mentioned this
Diane Feinstein's in the hospital the
Democratic party is you know with all
due respect to the elderly the geriatric
party at this point at least Republicans
have like you know that they're making
fun of the Republican party in CPAC for
the weirdos and the freaks you had Joe
Scarborough on MSNBC call them all
weirdos and freaks and I'm like at least
they're like young-ish
he's going to be 90 in June wow and
Nancy Pelosi is still in office it's
just a whole bunch of really old people
that are slowly dying it Democratic and
and young leftists don't like the
Democratic party so this could finally
be the end of this garbage political
party we need tournaments
I agree you know what about that wait I
got it party term limits
I mean you gotta change parties at some
point a Democrat cannot hold the same
office longer than two consecutive terms
or something like that unless they
become a republican so like no no any
party so we do this if this any any seat
a senator seat a congressional seat is
held by a Democrat for you know like
let's say term limits member of Congress
they can serve eight years after those
eight years you can't have the same
person or political party
oh you got to switch the whole thing up
well you know what I think I think they
should remove the D's and the R's on all
of the ballots agreed it should be
illegal that way because people will
change their name like hot lightning and
stuff and they'll get or like Aaron
Anderson
they'll be like if you can't you know if
you've got to represent yourself just
buy a piece of text on a paper when the
vote comes to stupid voters or people
that ignore John Democrat Smith yeah
they'll be like best choice would be the
name and they'll be like how does Best
Choice keep winning the elections these
nuts I'm kind of joking but I'm
concerned that just taking the D and the
RF wouldn't be enough because they'd
still in their names it is a start you
have to put your legal name so we went
to Congress uh a month ago and we spent
some time on their interview real quick
sorry correction we're not there this
week we're there next next Friday
um we interviewed them and I got a Vibe
of why they don't want seem to want
terminal and it's why there's pushback
because it's like a fraternity you go in
and they become such close tight battle
buddies good friends that like it's
almost like losing an arm to see one of
them have to go like Lauren bobert Matt
Gates like they're tight and if all of a
sudden Lauren disappears it's like dude
that's like part of our crew man it's
not just that they have to build their
offices when when we went there they
were explaining how you get an office
and then you have to do Remodeling and
you've got to set it up they give you
space that's all you get and the staff
is all integrated with people of other
staffs and stuff it's it's it's but you
know just that's not enough reason to
not have term limits in my opinion I
just see why there's resistance to it
party term limits and bureaucrat term
limits
I think the party term limit thing is we
could even one-up it and say
a Democrat uh a member of a party or I
should say a political party cannot have
a member serve
uh within like we do a gap term so if a
Democrat is in office for eight terms
then it can't be a Democrat for the next
eight terms
and it could only be so so basically
yeah that is after that it can be the
Democrats again so there's eight years
where it's not the Democratic party that
means they'll have to be a third party
because if a Democrat district has their
person term out they're not going to
vote Republican so it's got to be a
different political party and that could
mean there and there ends up with like
we end up with like four or five
different political parties that are
very similar but whatever I'll take it
break up the uh the duopoly of the
private political organizations that
control everything
[Music]
has that ever happened on Earth in any
government that the same party can't
hold power I don't know multiple terms
no idea thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time